-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy and Golden Globe-winning
actor you know from
"The X-Files,"
"The Fall," and "Sex Education."
She stars as Margaret Thatcher
in the fourth season
of "The Crown,"
which is streaming on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-The way those men patronize me,
lecture me --
the squires and grandies.
-Upper-class bastards.
-And their ideas,
their solutions
to the problems
this country faces,
so unimaginative
and cautious
and wet.
-Please welcome to the sho
Gillian Anderson.
How are you?
-I'm good.
Can you hear me?
-I can hear you great.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I'm such a big fan.
-Pleasure, pleasure. Same.
-I want to ask
about "The Crown,"
because it strikes me
that playing Margaret Thatcher
is a lot more fun
than it probably was
to be Margaret Thatcher.
Is an that probably
an accurate observation?
-Oh, interesting.
Well, definitely.
I think when you're surrounded
by people like Olivia Colman
and Josh O'Connor
and everybody else,
it's a fantastic cast,
and they make it a lot of fun.
And so we had a lot of fun
-Yeah, because I feel
like the real Margaret Thatche
probably never, like,
reclined quite like this.
[ Both laugh ]
-Maybe not.
-And certainly Margaret Thatcher
and the Queen never...
[ Laughter ]
I mean, of course, selfies
weren't as in vogue
when they were hanging out
together.
So there's no way of knowing
as a historical record,
if that would have happene
or not.
I think people might not know,
certainly in the States,
might not fully appreciate
how funny Olivia Colman is
as an actor and as a comedian.
And there was a video.
This was before pandemic,
when you guys
were shooting together.
But this was a funeral scene
and when the cameras
were not rolling,
the cellphones were,
and you guys were doing
a choreographed dance to Lizzo
How did this come about?
-Well, Olivia apparently
does a dance class,
in the area that she lives
with a bunch of friends,
on a regular basis.
And she -- And the last time
she did the class she was --
they had danced to that song -
that Lizzo song.
And she asked if we
would happen to be intereste
in maybe doing it,
and she would video it.
And then she would just share it
only with her friends...
-[ Laughs ]
-...the other dancers.
And so it was never meant
to see the light of day.
-And yet, here we are,
the light of day.
-And yet here we are.
-One.
-♪♪ I do my hair toss ♪♪
♪♪ Check my nails ♪♪
♪♪ Baby, how you feelin'?
♪♪ Feelin' good as hell ♪♪
♪♪ Hair toss ♪♪
♪♪ Check my nails ♪♪
♪♪ Baby, how you feelin'?
♪♪ Feelin' good as hell ♪♪
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-It's really good.
You guys are really good.
-So humiliating.
-[ Laughs ]
-That look on my face,
I don't even know.
I mean, there's
such delight and shame.
-I would like to say both,
but I think you did a better job
than Margaret Thatcher
would have done,
and also acknowledging
that I think
that's a pretty low bar.
[ Both laugh ]
-Thanks.
-It must be interesting
to play a character
like Margaret Thatcher,
who's so polarizing.
Like, there's nobody left,
I would guess,
who's on the fence
about how to feel about --
you know, like, "I need
a little bit more informatio
about Margaret Thatcher."
Does that make it interesting,
playing somebody like that
-Well, yeah.
I mean, I think most actor
are interested
in complex characters.
I don't think there is anyone,
maybe, historically,
who's as complex as she was,
and continues to be,
based on the very, very
strong feelings
that people continue
to have about her.
-It's not just, you know,
a voice
that you have to sort of adopt
but also it seems
like there is some,
like, facial contortions
that you went through to get
a proper Margaret Thatcher
-Yeah, I mean, we started ou
with teeth, trying to --
because she had
famously bad teeth.
And we tried with prosthetic
and stuff,
and none of that worked,
and then it came down
to kind of figuring out
maybe how to hold my face
differently,
so that I had buck teeth without
having buck teeth, sort of
Because she had "bucker" teeth
than I did.
[ Laughs ]
And so, yeah.
So there
is a kind of an overbite
that I adopted
in order to be her.
And so, yeah.
-Do you ever find yourself
like, even when you're not
playing the role,
do you find yourself,
like, drifting
into Margaret Thatcher face,
ever?
-[ Laughs ]
"Margaret Thatcher face."
Yeah, I only feel
like I'd let go of that
maybe about
three or four weeks ago.
We stopped shooting in February,
I think.
Because I would find mysel
watching, you know, television
with my kids or something
or reading a book
and realizing that my face
was in that position.
That overbite and, yeah.
And then I did
third season of "Sex Ed,"
and she kind of snuck in there
every once in a while.
I'd have to say.
"No, wait, wait, sorry.
You may not realize that,
but I know,
because she just
walked in the door.
Can we please do another take?
-There's a very unique
kind of person
who only wants
their sex education
from someone talking
like Margaret Thatcher,
and you are perfect for them
[ Laughs ]
-Great. Introduce me.
-Now, you mention your kids.
Do you have -- is it three boys?
-I have two boys and one girl.
-Two boys and one girl.
Do they engage with your work,
I would imagine?
Like, "Sex Education," again
that is about a mother
who's a sex therapist
who talks to her teenage son
Do your kids watch that?
And if so, is it
a difficult show for them
to watch,
or do they enjoy it?
-They're not supposed to.
They promised me
that they haven't seen it.
My boys are 12 and 14.
My 26-year-old daughter
is allowed to watch it.
But the boys, no.
Although I think
they might be lying.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I mean, if they can
find their way to Netflix,
you're probably
in a good degree of trouble.
-Yeah, I think
you might be right.
And for some reason, both of the
seasons that have aired so far
the very, very first scene
is literally worse
than anything that you see -
The first scene
on both first episodes are worse
than anything that follows
in any episode.
-Did you have to --
Is it true that you banned
I guess it's your boys,
from Instagram -- from
following you on Instagram
-From following me
on Instagram, yeah.
They're not allowed
to follow me.
'Cause, You know, I post -
I incite erection.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I post penises.
[ Laughter ]
I post penises on my Instagram
And what's a funicular?
I'm sorry.
I don't know
what a funicular is.
-I'm really glad you asked
A funicular is
like a subway
that goes up a hill.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-Okay. Thanks.
-By the way, I'm so happy --
I feel like, all our guests,
we waste their time.
But the fact
that you learned one thing -
[ Laughter ]
-I learned one thing.
-Usually, in nonpandemic times
you would come here
and you would leave
with a coffee mug, a T-shirt
maybe even a nice tote.
-[ Laughs ]
-That doesn't happen anymore
We can just give you
information.
[ Laughter ]
-Great.
-Thanks so much for being here
It was really delightful
talking to you.
-Same. Pleasure.
Nice to be here.
-the fourth season
of "The Crown"
is streaming on Netflix.